[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing characters
that were omitted from the films i feel
like you can't really criticize the
harry potter films that much unless the
filmmakers decided to convert the films
into a tv series and devote 20 hours to
each book there isn't really anything
they could do to make these amazing
movies any better
it's never an easy feat to translate
novels to the silver screen but somehow
harry potter successfully pulled it off
but in the process the filmmakers were
forced to shave a few of our favorite
characters from the final scripts
and even though they had their reasons
for doing so i can't help but feel that
something is missing without these
incredible wizards and witches
so today we're going to take a look at
some of the characters who failed to
make the jump to the big screen and what
they added to the harry potter mythos
1. ludo bagman ludo bagman was quite the
celebrity in the wizarding world as a
former star beater for the english
national quidditch team
most wizards and witches revered bagman
as a national hero and after bagman
retired from the sport he would need all
of that public goodwill to find a job
because bagman wasn't very bright and
actually was a bit of a degenerate
gambler
although he was once accused of being
aligned with death eaters his celebrity
status was more than enough to sway the
courts in his favor
ludo not only was cleared of all charges
he continued to climb the ladder of the
ministry of magic and was a department
head before he was forced to go into
hiding
his gambling debts had caught up to him
and he was wanted by the goblins for
failing to make his payments bagman came
to know harry well during the triwizard
tournament
living up to his reputation as an
affable buffoon
bagman didn't hesitate to give potter
illegal assistance in order to help the
wizard win
2. charlie weasley
charlie weasley was the second oldest
weasley child like his older sibling
bill charlie left hogwarts soon after
graduating and took off for abroad his
love for magical creatures led him to
specialize in the study of dragons and
he soon found himself in romania
dedicated to the protection and
preservation of the winged beasts
eventually he interacted with harry
potter's peers and mentors
during the young wizards time at
hogwarts when hagrid took care of a
young dragon named norbert norberta he
realized that the animal was far too
dangerous to be kept on the grounds
so he contacted ron's older brother and
sent norberta away
years later during the height of the
second wizarding war charlie weasley
arrived at the battle of hogwarts with a
contingent of international wizards and
helped turn the tides and defeat
voldemort
3. peeves
like nearly headless nick peeves was
another ancient spirit that haunted the
halls of hogwarts
but unlike nick who was a benevolent
being peeves was much more mischievous
he regularly harassed the students of
all years and would play pranks on both
pupils and teachers
the groundskeeper of hogwarts argus
filch hated peeves the most their
battles would rage throughout filtra's
time at the school
even though the old janitor regularly
asked albus dumbledore to kick peeves
off of the campus dumbledore refused in
the end during the battle of hogwarts
filch eventually came to peeves for help
and together they joined the fight
against the death eaters
4. frank and alice longbottom
frank and dallas longbottom were the
father and mother of neville longbottom
and two of the most important auras
during the first visiting war
it was during their tenure the ministry
of magic that many of lord voldemort's
most important death eaters were
apprehended and brought to justice
in the aftermath of professor trulani's
famous prophecy
frank and alice's only son neville was
deemed as one of the two children who
could have fulfilled it
shortly after a group of death eaters
led by bellatrix to strange apprehended
frank and alice and tortured them so
much that they were permanently mentally
incapacitated
they spent the rest of their days in a
care facility within mungo's hospital
for magical maladies and injuries and
the burden of their fates led their son
to his heroic service during the battle
of hogwarts
5. winky winky was one of the many house
elves that harry potter came to know
during his time at hogwarts
while most remember the mouth for his
elf dobby and the black family servant
creature you might have forgotten about
winky she served the crouches before she
was eventually let go and given a job at
hogwarts
in the very final confrontation between
harry potter and voldemort winky was one
of the elves who fought alongside
dumbledore's army and the new order of
the phoenix
6. the gaunts the gaunts were once a
pureblood family as celebrated as the
crouchers or malfoy's but by the 20th
century the gaunt's paranoia about other
families pureblood status had led them
to interbreed for generations the end
result was a final generation of gaunts
that were mentally deficient broke and
plagued with melancholy
one of them a girl named merapi decided
to break the tradition that her family
had started and instead of marrying a
pureblood from her gene pool
she seduced a muggle named tom riddle
together they conceived a son
but after merapi released tom from her
spell the man abandoned her
the subsequent months were filled with
even more tragedy and all of this
eventually moulded her child into the
future dark wizard lord voldemort
7. andromeda and ted tonks
andromeda and ted tonks were the parents
of nymphadora tonks the wife of rumus
lupin and a member of the order of the
phoenix
andromeda and ted weren't just any old
witch and wizard but were actually part
of the black family and through them
related to the malfoys weasleys
lestrangers and even tom riddle
the blacks were a pureblood family so
when andromeda announced her plans to
marry ted a wizard with muggle heritage
she was blasted off the family portrait
and outcast
8. dennis crevey
dennis cravey was the younger brother of
colin kravi and the student several
years younger than harry potter
dennis during his time at hogwarts
definitely played the part of younger
sibling to all the members of
dumbledore's army and often ended up in
situations where he needed to be saved
by the time lord voldemort's death
eaters escalated conflicts and
officially began the second wizarding
war dennis would only have a short time
with his brother during the battle of
hogwarts colin who was still a teenager
at the time was killed in the bloody
fight
leaving dennis alone to survive him
9. phineas black
vinnius black was one of sirius black's
ancestors
and a member of the black family who
propagated its proud pureblood
traditions
during his time in the early 20th
century venus became quite an
accomplished sorcerer and eventually
earned the seat of headmaster at
hogwarts
one of the few slytherin to do so
although as headmaster he was hardly
beloved
many of the students despised phineas
for his cold
boring educational philosophy but in
later years vinnies actually proved to
be an asset
when his far more progressive minded
successor albus dumbledore sought advice
the portrait of phineas black often
offered it although whether or not
dumbledore followed it was a different
matter and later while on the hunt for
horcruxes venus's portrait helped harry
potter and his friends by accident as he
reported their whereabouts to severus
snape who secretly aided them
10. augusta longbottom augusta long
bottom was neville longbottom's
grandmother and his guardian in the
years that followed the unfortunate
attack on his parents
although augusta has a brief moment in
the first harry potter film she was
never seen again except for some cut
scenes from the deathly hallows part two
although augusta cared more about
neville than the dursleys did about
harry she was still quite a tough nut to
crack
she regularly criticized devil's choices
and even publicly shamed him for his
lack of achievements
it wasn't until neville became a hero of
gryffindor that she eventually
recognized his merits as a wizard 11.
carcass
carcass was a humongous terrifying giant
and the predecessor of golgomath the
giant who served in voldemort's army
for a brief time carcass was the leader
of the giants a position that was known
as gerg
while acting as gerg carcas didn't do
much the title was his because he had
won it in battle or because he was so
terrifyingly large that nobody did fight
him for it
asgard carcass wasn't obligated to work
so he spent his days resting within a
lake
waiting for his fellow giants to serve
him meal after meal
once during the events that led to the
second wizarding war dumbledore and
hagrid ventured dukakis to win his
support over the days that followed it
seemed like carcass would be willing to
align himself with the order of the
phoenix and fight against lord voldemort
but in a sudden twist of events
carcasses rival a giant named golgomath
decapitated him took his rank and swore
his allegiance to the death eaters
12. teddy lupin
teddy lupin was the orphan son of tonks
and remus
after the battle of hogwarts both of his
parents were slain by the invading death
eater army leaving lupin without any
parents
in the years it followed his surviving
grandmother andromeda raised him
but she had help before their death
tonks and remus named harry potter as
teddy's godfather and throughout his
childhood potter tried to fulfill the
role to the best of his ability
and that's it for this video
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
you